hey what's going on a spill burn it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast ad
[Music]
just checking in on you
how are you hanging with my wife on a
rainy day and [ __ ] it hey what's up
hi how are ya yeah there was a reason I
brought you on this podcast well Mia as
you know I am a blowhard yes I talk and
talk and talk and talk to the point that
I fall asleep there you guys wait
so I actually ran to a question the
other day believe it or not believe it
or not right that's it
I'm walking on air someone sanded me a
[ __ ] question I couldn't answer it it
blew my mind cuz even if I don't know
the answer I still [ __ ] talk to these
people right that's a great song let me
get that piece of [ __ ] get the piece of
fuzz off your mic this well they're made
for men that's why these are men chairs
I need an ottoman
these are anti Beach ok all right cuz
this is this is a loners you keep
calling this a mancave it's not a
mancave I don't call it mancave call it
a mancave it's my office
I don't ever call it a mancave I never
call it that Wow just like that on the
podcast you're gonna lie I've never said
I was gonna go to your office that's
what I want two banishing you from what
Mia
oh now you're backing down from it I
believe you called this gaslighting you
making me seem like I'm crazy maybe I'm
crazy anyway so this person had a
question and it's a very delicate
subject Nia I write delicate like my
feelings you know people's not as much
as I go onstage night after night and I
try to act like I'm this tough person if
you really took the time to know me
you'd know that it was volition that's
true
oh you talk so much [ __ ] see this is the
problem this is why people oh boy
it's like people really think it's
interesting to me how well your fans
think they know you because you have
this persona on stage and you're the
angry guy and that's certainly true let
me tell you but you're also just so full
of [ __ ] like you just talk something
like you're all talk you just talk and
talk but you're just full of [ __ ]
because you are such a sensitive like
giving like you know it's all good [ __ ]
yeah but it's annoying because it's like
you're walking around like you know like
choking the [ __ ] microphone stand
like you do take the good with the bed
people are like oh god you guys went to
Paris I bet bill hated that and it's
like no it's actually like his favorite
city oh wow you guys went to the beach I
bet bill hated that no we actually had a
good time it's just so weird there's
like this disconnect fan again that's
always like oh god I bet bill hated that
and also it's like any time he's kind of
picture on Instagram all of your fans
God love ya but all of your fans are
like oh I bet bill you know they just
will find something to bring you into
it'll be like a post of my feet like Oh
Billy likes the no shoes or whatever the
[ __ ] it is it's like it's it's crazy and
what's wrong with Ted I mean nothing but
it's just annoying Wow all that yelling
that's all you had I know I was like
you're an understand are you gonna knock
me out lunch you know I really wanna
drag me up here it didn't suck die I've
gone all for two in that place I know
for two it's not bad everything and
there's good I just never order the good
stuff yeah
I tried it I decided to take a risk and
it didn't quite pay off but it was so
nice to have lunch with you I know and
then we cuz we were you in too much food
I know no I must know about that we were
eating the food and we realized we
ordered too much so we cancelled one of
the pizzas right any
which pizza do you want to cancel yeah
and I didn't want to [ __ ] offend you
getting out [ __ ] pizza me too if I
say abusing my white male privilege by
saying let's just get the simple sausage
one yeah you had to go at the [ __ ]
Wiener schnitzel whatever the hell you
got yeah it was so good but it just
wasn't satisfying I think is the word
you're looking for are you impressed how
I've been getting up early and going to
the gym not really I mean you're still
on European time so it's naturally not
bad we'll be right back with searching
for a compliment maybe you know what it
has nothing to do with me being
jet-lagged okay because you snore like a
[ __ ] offensive lineman you go through
these periods you have such a cute
little nose how does all that noise
noise come out of there cuz I'm sleeping
hard and I'm sleeping right this thing
that you're doing now where every
[ __ ] five minutes you're shaking me
in the bed like that doesn't let's
explain let's explain yes does it wakes
you up and you stop for a second she
starts [ __ ] storm doing this [ __ ] so
what I do is I'm laying on my side away
from her and then what I do is I just
start shaking the bed I don't and it
wakes her up and she would huh the
second you close your eyes
yeah it doesn't stop me from snoring so
I like what is the point of units my
love house really starting to piss me
off
well I told you I will [ __ ] sleep
somewhere else okay alright but I've
done that before and then after two
nights you like you and you're woke up
wait with me he's doing the key noise
well so what are we supposed to do I
snore you wake up we don't want to sleep
apart from each other yes the ocean I'm
ugly enough so I need as much beauty
sleep I can get don't say that but but
yeah
I guess I could get one of those Breathe
Right strips or something like you're
breathing wrong baby because I never
used to snore like that before the baby
so I don't know I just think you're
extra tired I'm see you snore
the way I imagine I snore after I but I
drink like a third a bottle of [ __ ]
booze you were snoring earlier in the
night when you first fell asleep last
night cuz I took that Mel at times I'm
gonna taking that to get myself back on
and it's [ __ ] work great okay so I
mean I don't know I don't know what to
tell you
hey I still love you right now it's just
I won't be passed out laying next to you
anymore just stop shaking the beds
because it works it works a lot of times
you roll over you know you stopped like
20 minutes but now I know you just like
relentless she's like the [ __ ]
terminator is sleeping top I think I
blew you up or some [ __ ] you just
[ __ ] come back together again you
start snoring
so I'm like oh my god some coin why am I
here what you call me in here for what
is I don't know cuz you know what I made
a new year's resolution that I wasn't
gonna argue with you as much what yeah
you made a new year's resolution that
you're not gonna argue with me and it's
been working so I need you to explain
this what does that mean I'm just gonna
agree with you is that what you think
that I want yes
she says Christ it's like no winning
there's no winning I like arguing with
you hasn't worked I'll disagree with you
all right I'm not trying that like
cutoff like the balls of your opinion I
just need you to not be an [ __ ] I
don't know how to do that oh really yeah
come on I'm an [ __ ] he married an
[ __ ] but that what but that's kind of
not fair in your sight but you married
an [ __ ] and now you want me to not be
an [ __ ] I didn't realize why knew you
were jerks I knew you were a journal you
know what it is I thought you were like
a bad boy and then the bad boy turns
into like a bad man and then but you're
not a bad boy you're just like you're
just grumpy and before I was like oh
you're edgy like he's edgy like it
doesn't take any [ __ ] man that's cuz you
are a casting director you put me in
this box man yeah all right
he could play 28 to 35 he's edgy you
weren't even looking at me like a person
as you've gotten older you've just
become like so cranky somebody was like
all bilborough's gonna make the best
like cranky old man it's gonna be
hilarious and it's like yeah I have to
live with that it's gotta be so hard
you're so brave me yeah what am I gonna
call my memoir surviving bill burr be
coming no it's just like I said it's
annoying cuz you're actually a very
sweet person
but everybody sees this this angry
jackass no they don't people want they
don't yes they like me believe it or not
Nia they
people beyond the walls of this [ __ ]
relationship that actually liked me that
branded they don't have to live with me
I know I'm difficult to live with I'm
literally telling you I'm gonna try to
just [ __ ] agree whatever harebrained
[ __ ] idea you have that's gonna take
up the whole [ __ ] day you want to go
after the coca mocha well cos [ __ ]
thing all the way up to five yeah let's
just play off football going on I'll
tape it you did not take my games while
I was away I thought I tape all your
Kardashian horseshit whenever you're
asked did you tape Sebastian did you
tape Sebastian on the [ __ ] news store
you missed that tow caught up with the
baby I forget but I really thought that
I'd taped all your games while you were
gone cuz i sat there when I searched one
the other two came up so I was like oh
great record record record Sebastian was
on like the [ __ ] NBC Nightly News and
he was walking around the comedy store
talking about the history of play but
yes I did forget to DVR it so I
apologize for that you're right hey
you're right we'll search for it online
wait for somebody to put it online I'd
love to go to couples therapy would you
why because I feel like if there was
another person there going a you know
maybe bill has a point
I could win one once once just one the
transplants if I could find a way I know
what could be your [ __ ] douche you
and a lot of them is the thing you just
don't realize that you do yeah wow
that's that's probably the biggest mind
[ __ ] you've ever given me you win a lot
of them you just don't realize you do so
you're so good that even when I'm
winning I feel like I lose that's what
you tell it that is an amazing skill I
don't know if I'd be proud of it fair
enough you're taking my lines I love it
fair enough well you know what Nia we
went out to lunch today we did some
other things that I'm not allowed to
talk about yet because they you know but
I have to wait to the official
announcement comes about you know I am
I'll give you an idea
something that's going on with me and it
rhymes with rands ich Ihnen i and we're
gonna try to make this relationship work
is iran's ition from a [ __ ] douche
what if I loved you so much I transition
to a woman that enjoyed the Kardashians
that's not what I was Clyde I just got I
think so thank God it's so weird you
know I watched that show but I hate them
it's like so it's such a weird thing
I am I hate watching it do you think I
know I don't I don't know what I don't
know I don't believe in hate watching I
think that's so juvenile and like
ridiculous that's probably some sort of
like this probably yeah you know at some
point you'll be able to get in trouble
with that on social media I'm sure you
Renee he'll accused of hate watching I
don't recall hate watching but if I did
hate watch I'd like to apologize to the
producers of those shows on my phone and
I'm just kind of like in and out like I
don't even really know what's going on
but it's just there and they're talking
at me and I know I don't have a good
explanation for it no idea if you enjoy
that show god damn it you watch it okay
and also other terrible reality shows so
what's your top three terrible reality
shows rules ah Real Housewives
I don't mind Vanderpump rules you don't
yeah yeah you like those goods I know
just something like I don't get what I
don't understand how you get a job at a
restaurant and your manager becomes your
life coach there's just something
hilarious about that to me yeah she's
like the mother figure but it's just
yeah and as far as I can tell is she
married is she married she's been
married for like the longest time oh she
is like young beautiful Fame [ __ ]
drama so the skinny dude who cried like
I love that she stuck to her guns she
did kids a mess that kids a mess he
deserves to be fired together you fired
me I don't know what that happened it
just seemed like it was the longest I've
ever seen somebody he had no argument he
just kept I don't know that's what it
felt like he was saying so they let that
guy go he's fired off the show for what
not the show he's still on the show he's
just because he gets really drunk and he
says really nasty things for the people
that worked there namely the girls and
he's always like you're fat [ __ ]
[ __ ] great I love that guy don't fire
him and then the other guy Jack's right
I was hoping he's gonna get that job at
the hockey club Yeah right
his whole thing with all that he was
gonna tweet he's gonna do social media
for like a minor-league florida-based
hockey team so a [ __ ] job is that
that's a job tweet for them in what way
got a game coming up yeah you're
generating excitement ah yeah if this
fights and there's good hits and it
seems like a good game and people want
to come out to buy tickets and spend
money yeah that's what you do okay just
Christ you can follow restaurants on
Instagram I just started following this
amazing cheese board account and you're
making fun of this guy with a hockey
team there's somebody running a cheese
board account god it's amazing ain't you
proud too Meg cuz her name is Meg Megan
oh I thought those kind of cheese I was
like Meg oh it's monster cheese what
other cheese is beginning name a cheese
that begins with M monster monster okay
now you're the second person on the
family feud you got to come up another
one what are you
Oh mild cheddar cheddar bang why is that
a bad cuz the cheese it's gotta be mild
cheddar no that's a kind of cheddar
cheddar see I don't know you got
something else Monterey Jack Monterey
Jack let's have any family members you
can go to alright we as the hunter bleep
who named a cheese the begins with em we
got manchego man Chango show me [ __ ]
unbelievable
I love cheese alright this is [ __ ]
amazing
alright family number four okay wait
chunk and cheese begins with an L that's
a lovely necklace you have it
richard dawson kids all right we need a
cheese that begins with M or the
Sullivan family as a chance to steal
what do you got got one strike with the
mild cheese oh come on give me a guess
in three two one
I do the Steve Harvey I asked you to
name a cheese because an M and you said
Montebello I got nothing show me
Montebello I got nothing dude that's
amazing that you could do that Munsters
all I had that's why I married you
because you know all the cheese's but I
better pepper all right what do you want
me to read the the advertising and then
we'll do the question right
Oh me undies me undies cut enough
[ __ ] cheese dudududu biondi's me
undies [ __ ] down to your knees run it
down your [ __ ] tighty whities it
would be better if you had me undies and
cradle that [ __ ] and no one would know
and your balls a feel nice and soft and
a little warm sorry
wait can i interject real quick sure me
undies sent us some onesies
and they are the most comfortable soft
things ever and I truly love them and
this is not a part of what they asked us
to read but like no I just want to say
thank you me on DS for the onesies and
everyone I never got my onesie you did I
put it on your yeah what happened to it
it feels a little weird to be an adult
dressing like a six-month-old baby
like can you talk about Michael it's a
little more put it on and we'll take a
picture we'll post on Instagram and
we'll do hashtag Mandy's hashtag add a
shag spark on do you know what spark on
is no sponsored content oh I'll tell you
what I'm just gonna read this article
look at here that's something good right
I'm gonna agree with you hey deal that's
not a great idea 20:19 Billy bird
he's got no opinion here all right
Valentine's Day is right around the
corner what are you gonna get me once
your [ __ ] take me out this year steak
in a [ __ ]
please Nene rather than spending all
that money going out to fancy
restaurants why not just hang in hang in
your underwear all night long courtesy
of me undies they got that little trap
to unto me undies so I can bang you from
behind you talk about why me undies are
the best underwear feel free to
improvise all right here we go
I love [ __ ] my wife in me Anzhi
onesies all right I'm a minute man I'm
done in one minute
the whole thing just it all works me on
z1z minivans get it done before 8:00
p.m. so I am seven minutes is a great
number I feel like that's fine
you know what a man's fine
I'm not trying to get banged like for
hours on end it's like well he's not fit
you don't do any work you just [ __ ]
laying there I'm up there like a [ __ ]
jackhammer what does what does what does
how many [ __ ] minutes I got to do did
you do plank for seven minutes cuz
that's what the [ __ ] I have to do I got
to get up off yeah and drop it down yeah
you're not one of those cuddlers you're
like get away from me come back get away
from me come back feel like a [ __ ]
astronaut spinning around with one's a
little rubber balls there Yanni's uses
it uses the coveted micro motile modal
fabric which is three times softer than
cotton yes that's why that onesie was so
comfortable
Thank You fab the fabric generally feels
like actual heaven against your skin
this person has had a near-death
experience where God came down and
tickled this little privates there oh my
god I need an underwear that feels like
the hand of God welcoming my balls to
the pearly gates only to say your work
is not finished speaking of Prince hmm
it's a segue this video G this vide a
season the undies will be releasing a
new print every Tuesday a heart shaped
like a dick how does that word that
means you and your loved ones can chill
and matching prints for v-day and play
the game of how long can we keep these
odds we'll be back after these messages
the Christmas ones I love them but why
stop at undies this year me undies is
launching their v-day prince in lounge
pants and onesies as well both are made
from the same micro modal Modell fabrics
as their undies me undies has a great
offer for my listeners for any
first-time purchasers when you order me
undies you get 15% off and free shipping
this is a no brainer
get 15% off a pair of the most
comfortable Under
you will ever put on to get your fifty
fifteen percent off your first pair free
shipping and a hundred percent
satisfaction guarantee go to me undies
talk comm / / that's my undies comm / /
by the way Nia you're not exactly you
kind of you know you get what you need
to be pretty quick too yeah that's yeah
you were definitely in touch with your
body yeah there you go
beat it other side of the bed I'm going
to sleep put on my Bose headsets you
listen to those screaming [ __ ] Dollar
Shave Club that's why your dad never
calls you [ __ ] Darla's shave club has
everything you need why are you walking
the street [ __ ] what happened what
happened what happened Dollar Shave Club
what that's that chick on the [ __ ]
subway just kept going what happened
what happened then he [ __ ] the guy
with the eight-ball jacket and he
[ __ ] watch on I was a different woman
what happened woman was another one
plumbing hit Dollar Shave Club has
everything you need to look feel and
smell your best and you never have to go
to the store that's because they deliver
everything right to you right to your
front door and they keep you fully
stocked on what you use so you don't run
out here's how it works Dollar Shave
Club is everything you need to get ready
no matter what you're getting ready for
they have you covered head to toe for
your hair your skin your face you name
it they gave it and they have this new
program where they automatically keep
you stocked up on products you use you
determine what you want and when you
want it and it shows right up at your
front door or back door whatever you
want alright throw it right through the
window if you want from once a month to
once every six months plus with their
handsome discount the more you buy the
more you save and right now Dollar Shave
Club has a bunch of this status sets you
can try for just five dollars like their
oral care kit after that the restock box
ships regular size products at a regular
price get your status set for just five
dollars dude right now at
dollarshaveclub.com / / that's jolly
shaved club.com / burr alright last one
quit qu eye
starting a healthy routine and sticking
to it
are two very different things inevitably
we all skimp on that full night of sleep
skip a workout or two or brush our teeth
with a tired old toothbrush we're not
perfect but we can do better and quip is
a better electric toothbrush that can
help oh they're only solving that I
thought they'd want to help all the
other [ __ ] I'm gonna sleep well and work
out and brush my teeth sorry bill we're
just gonna fix brushing your teeth
sensitive sonic vibrations for an
effective clean that's gentle on your
sensitive gums Jase what are women going
to use this for brush heads are
automatically delivered on a dentist
recommended schedule which dentist do I
know this guy can I see his credentials
every three months for just $5 a
friendly reminder when it's time for a
refresh and to stay committed to your
own or oral health seventy-five percent
of us use old worn-out bristles that are
ineffective
Equipe is one of the most is one of the
first electric toothbrushes accompanied
by the accepted sorry by the American
Dental Association they are backed by
over twenty five thousand dental
professionals geez you thought being a
comedian was [ __ ] competitive there's
25,000 there's 25 dental professionals
out there who just agree with this yeah
you get all the ones that disagree I
mean you know I'm surprised they're not
out there shooting each other like drug
dealers and they have thousands shoot
each other with novocaine no sorry and
they have thousands of verified verified
five-star reviews over 1 million happy
healthy mouths do to quip starts just 25
bucks and if you go to get quit GE tqu
IP comm slash bar right now
you can get your first refill pack for
that's your first refill pack for a fee
at GE tqu i p.com slash / there it is
alright and lastly but not leastly i
love when you do the podcast Nia you
know it's great you're funny you kill it
always girlfriend won't lose weight dear
Billy not so fat this is from the other
day okay it's a very delicate situation
yes I'm here okay
my girlfriend and I have been dating for
three years going on four and I'm
starting to have different feelings
towards her because of her eating habits
and the way she takes care of herself
since I met her several years ago she
had cut she kind of had a weight thing
that was noticeable but didn't think
anything of it because I thought she
would get on some sort of kick of
wanting to lose some weight in the years
to come
well it's been three and a half years
and we already making a face over there
and there's no stopping her from losing
weight weight losing weight she's 25 and
I'm 30 and I don't know what to do she
loves to see he meant gaining weight she
loves the sweets and is not a fan of
running because it hurts her feet help
bill I love her but I don't want to
spend my early 30s miserable in a
relationship with someone who doesn't
want to take care of herself thanks and
go [ __ ] yourself now what does he say to
her first of all mother [ __ ] you fell
in love with her when she was a little
thick and you were just like oh so lose
weight but you still fell for her and
now you're mad that the [ __ ] is gaining
weight
it's like she obviously likes to eat you
knew that from jump so why are you
getting extra Street on this one
mother [ __ ] from the jump okay so what
so what's the problem
she won't she just keeps gaining weight
[ __ ] be getting fat and all right vhat
all right my in it am I in the club no
you know for a second cuz it makes her
feet yet jogging is terrible for your
knees so hurt your feet there's other
ways but I mean I don't know
don't you think okay I'll play devil's
advocate here alright you can't get what
you get with somebody and you're at a
particular way you got a hover in that
zone yeah okay you can't get
reality-show fat on them I'm just saying
it let me ask you this then at what
point
remember how pasty I am yeah
all right oh I remember come stairs
every day
my bit I just start looking like a
[ __ ] snowman and then suddenly my gut
when you know when it gets it can't go
out anymore and it starts to drop and it
starts hanging over your [ __ ] junk a
little bit well you know I mean you
can't tell me you're not gonna be like
going like hey hey they have a Michelin
Man what are you doing with it because
I've never had a problem with a little
extra on a guy I've never like thought
it was like oh he's too fat for me or
whatever like crazy obese sure that's
what I'm saying watch what you know on
the thicker side he's not saying that I
think that's where she started and now
she was a thick e that maybe could have
taken a couple blow couple laps around
the block and he still got with her and
he's been with her three years since
like is she eating by herself
yeah he looked at her the way met women
look at men along time this is a
fixer-upper mm-hmm and then he bought
the house and all of a sudden well
that's your problem I've said it before
on this podcast and I'll say it again
you don't fall in love with potential
it's a trap all right now can you help
the guy out well he always loves her how
does he go listen tubby you know and you
[ __ ] lay off the [ __ ] strawberry
shortcake here well maybe let's see what
would I say lead by example and be like
you know what I want to be healthy like
I want to cook healthy like I want to
exercise more like what do you think you
want to do it with me and that can be
like a thing oh that's how you do I
don't know is to say I think women are
too smart they'll see through you saying
I'm fat
yeah if I came up you said hey I've been
thinking about eating some wrestle
sprouts you wanted some Brussels sprouts
with me yeah he's saying I'm fat you
[ __ ] bald red [ __ ] that's what would
come out of your mouth this guy
obviously yeah wants to be with this
person right it's up me rights it
already but yeah but read that last part
again I love her but like say that again
read that last part okay I love her but
I don't want to spend my early 30s
miserable and
elation ship with someone who doesn't
want to take care of herself yeah this
is this [ __ ] thing about people being
fat [ __ ] now and being proud of it it's
like you're killing yourself you're
gonna die you're gonna I am NOT a doctor
but I can't say that and I just did and
I can say that because that's like me
saying I smoking cigarettes you're gonna
get lung cancer you're not a doctor I
can't say that does she not work out at
all that's what he's saying she's
sitting there and she's eating and she's
getting fatter and fatter and that's not
fair to the other person there I know
but you know what sometimes it's not
about the other person sometimes you're
going through something sometimes you
just want to [ __ ] in two years you don't
wanna think about dieting and exercising
all the time and being caught in that
circle of constantly like I need to die
I need to exercise I need to die do you
need a unique you need to learn how to
eat well maybe that's not something that
she feels like doing right now I feel
like I'm talking about myself because I
want to lose weight I'm trying to lose
this baby weight but like I just look
great
this isn't about you it's about this
person you're self-centered necessarily
being on that goddamn hamster wheel I
want to go back to my trainer now that
I've recovered from my hernia surgery
I'm gonna get back into it but like to
think about eating healthy all the time
and exercising all the time like
sometimes you just don't [ __ ] want to
are you gonna dump me are you gonna like
kick me to the curb
who you yeah do you realize how [ __ ]
insane you are right now like this was
literally about another woman and you're
[ __ ] yelling at me like I said it I'm
trying to help this kid out so he can
need loves this woman and you know it it
is it's a good thing to lose weight it's
not good for you every five every pound
of fat is a hundred miles of capillaries
somebody told me that one time so every
time your heart beats yes I don't
remember but I know but the thing is if
you put that weight on in this there's
more mass your body has to grow more
capillaries so because that party would
die it needs oxygen oxygenated blood I
came to say it right
oxygenate
that's a tough one oxygenated God we had
a kid Wow okay yeah you can't just so it
has to grow that's and then that's an
extra like you know it's like a paper
route there's an extra five customers
everyday can you remove yourself I can't
it's alright okay fair enough all right
well you know what buddy I tried you
what would you do I would buy a ukulele
and I would write a silly song about how
she needs to get in shape and I would
say that my dick wrote it so they
wouldn't be mad at me seriously though I
would tell her that listen I never told
this before no because when I go down on
you now
I'm starting to get claustrophobic
because I feel like the walls are
closing in from both sides and from
above and I just feel like I can't
breathe is there a way no I don't know
what I would say you're beautiful I love
you but if you don't hit the treadmill
I'm gonna buy a human leash and start
dragging around the block do this yoga
class with me after work we could do
couples yoga together what I feel like
oh that's what you said through you
asking if I'm gonna [ __ ] yoga class
no but you have to I think if you're if
you're really concerned about though
seriously you should suggest that you do
stuff that's healthy together like let's
cook meals together let's go to yoga
class I actually think like that's
that's it I feel like that's nicest way
to do it without making the person feel
like you're singling them out or you
know why do I think she put any stuff
see listen I want to get into really
good shape I feel like I'm not in the
shape I want to be in
and I was you know when I was to be in
better shape before I met you just make
that [ __ ] up and say because I used to
go to the gym with a buddy of mine she's
gonna see through all of this yeah just
nice and easy I am like the way you make
me some healthy smoothies every morning
something like that cuz I appreciate
that does healthy smoothies okay well
you know what this is a tough one that's
one of the hardest ones that Hey Hey
ladies any ladies out there right in and
and how can a guy or how would you tell
haha yeah how can a man tell a woman you
know that he loves he wants to stay with
her but she's putting on [ __ ] weight
you know and it's he's he's helping her
out Nia I know but like her body
obviously like he fell in love with
something else about her yeah you can't
say that look it's an if you fell in
love with the guy and then he puts on
weight he's his pot-smoking [ __ ] guy
with like there's ways that women can
fall out of love with with the guy that
they fell in love with because he's
letting himself go because he stopped
going after it because he's partying too
much there's all thing and and putting
on weight is in that okay like someone
like to fall in love with someone and
then a couple years later they're like
literally twice the size that they are
that's not that that's selfish behavior
what else is going on in their life
because maybe there's something that's
leading to that extra eating or stress
eating or whatever maybe there's
something else going on but anybody just
be a lazy [ __ ] and they're just eating
[ __ ] sundaes why does it always have
to be like I get touched funny by my
mailman so now I use [ __ ] cocoa be on
the superficial and to see what's in
someone's heart and mind you know what
that's probably right my thing is I owe
a berry everything so I just get up like
a [ __ ] robot
I mean it's working for me but I
understand I don't know I don't I had I
had well you know when I accomplished I
accomplished how difficult this is such
a difficult thing to talk about you know
and
you know you know [ __ ] be getting fat
I don't know what to tell you I'm joking
I'm joking all right there you go Nia I
think you look beautiful I've been
trying to bang you for like a [ __ ]
since I came back that's some Europe you
know tried all my smooth lines you know
like can you do something about this
over here about a little attaboy over
here even grabbing me in restaurants and
things like that
yep then do me a favor you know don't
put yourself out all right you know find
it in your [ __ ] heart why according
to you I don't do anything I just
apparently I just lie there and just
take it and don't purchase I'm sorry
I believe you cue [ __ ] on me first what
do you mean you criticize my performance
first I got defensive and I say that
yeah you're a [ __ ] animal in bed I
never said that you weren't alright well
there you go we'll stop acting like I'm
not [ __ ] doing something for you you
are doing you're doing a lot for me
don't love it
Oh Nia you know something L you know
what you're not as complex as you like
to act okay
you don't think I'm running around in
there but I'm in there I'm between those
ears yeah great comeback oh my god all
right jerkface thanks for hanging out
with me this for having me oh we got to
bring up William Stephenson a sad thing
here after all the laughs another great
comic another great friend and just
somebody white I must have done I feel
like I did a million shows with William
Stephenson unfortunately he passed away
I believe was on Monday of this week and
I'm gonna miss that guy
I just we we used to have so many
running jokes cuz we always used to do
late-night shows in New York City and I
remember that's stupid McDonald's thing
came out but a pop up I'm loving it and
we would just come in and every time we
would sing something different but up
but by I'm [ __ ] it or just something
stupid and it would just always make us
laugh we would always do it on like the
third
show when it was like half the [ __ ]
room was full and you know what I got to
find it I have a great picture of me in
him back when I had hair and greg
Giraldo yeah
probably sad photo I guess I'm next on
that photo well it's how it works new
you know it's like a forest fire okay
you burned down a redhead and awesome
some brunettes grow all right so rest in
peace William you're one of the Great's
and definitely gonna miss you and thank
you to the Comedy Cellar and all those
clubs that I got to work with them in he
was just with the he was the best host
used to host the shows he was the
[ __ ] best and I never heard him say a
bad word about anybody so and he was a
hell of a musician too he used to do but
I didn't know that he played music - oh
yeah he's Jeff Ross used to go on stage
with them and he would play this really
cool perfect accompanying music when
Jeff used to do his poems right you know
and he was just it worked great and they
had so much fun together on stage which
is I gotta be honest when I was watching
bumping mics with with Jeff and Dave
Attell it reminded me of that and I got
to tell you there's something about I
don't know there was something about
that two comics going onstage watching
them have fun and you end up seeing they
see like I've never seen Dave like smile
as much as that it's it's been great to
watch so anyways rest in peace William
Stephenson another great comic gone so
anyways that's that's the podcast you
guys have a great weekend enjoy the
music and there'll be another half hour
of a greatest hit Thursday afternoon
Podcast to follow this in other 30
minutes all right that's it it the
treadmill you son of [ __ ]
[Music]
but I can't be
my cups already
[Music]
but it's on a table the fire
[Applause]
and the bombing baby lives
[Music]
blood
me
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the Monday morning podcast from
Monday January 17th 2011 that I'm
actually doing Tuesday morning Tuesday
[ __ ] morning and I know why a lot of
you think I am you probably thought I
was grieving for an extra 24 hours
because the Patriots lost to the [ __ ]
hated green [ __ ] Jets actually no I was
in Atlantic City I was in Atlantic City
and uh you know I didn't bring the
podcast all the [ __ ] equipment back I
came into New York on [ __ ] Tuesday I
don't want to be lugging that [ __ ]
around and then lug it down there and
like an [ __ ] I didn't realize I had a
6:00 o'clock in the evening flight I'm
kind of famous for that I never know
when my flights leave I'm always like
yeah I think I leave around 10 a.m. and
then I find out at 6 a.m. as I'm sitting
at a bar drinking at 3 in the morning
and then I go oh [ __ ] well this it's no
reason to go to bed now is there um
anyway so let's let's get down to brass
[ __ ] tacks here uh this is gonna kill
me um out of all the podcasts that I've
done for the last I'm just loving how
excited the Jets fans are right now I
know they're sitting there with their
[ __ ] ear cupped right up to the
goddamn speaker probably giving their
[ __ ] boss the finger [ __ ] you
[ __ ]
I was waiting all season for this
there's a big [ __ ] crow laying on his
plate and I'm gonna watch him eat every
goddamn [ __ ] bite and the feathers
yeah out of all the podcasts I've had to
do this is this is gonna be one of the
toughest ones toughest things I'm ever
gonna have to say congratulations to the
New York Jets their organization of
their fans you [ __ ] deserved it you
went up there you were talking [ __ ] and
you [ __ ] won the game and that's
that's it you want it you won the
[ __ ] game and this is what I think
happened during the game I thought both
teams came out there was so much [ __ ]
hype
before that game and I as always was not
a nervous Nellie all week you know as
from as much [ __ ] as I talk about the
Jets and [ __ ] if you notice when they
play the Patriots I never claim that
we're gonna win remember that remember
when we were forty five to three gay
member that before the and I was going I
got a I got a bad feeling man
that's from being a Boston sports fan
pre winning championships I just always
I'm waiting for the misery um and I was
getting into and this is nothing that I
didn't like I didn't like that everyone
was saying the Patriots were gonna win
and everyone was saying that I got to
the airport you know this is me going to
New York you go to the airport Patriots
are on the cover of Sports Illustrated
and I know people go the [ __ ] chicks
you know the Sports Illustrated jinx you
ever think that maybe they just don't
know how to pick a winner you ever think
maybe that maybe that's their [ __ ]
problem I saw that and then I was
watching a little bit of ESPN the only
thing I liked was the Jets were talking
[ __ ] and I was like I hope they keep
doing this just keep doing this and I
hope they get off the plane wearing
fatigues like the [ __ ] Miami
Hurricanes that's what I was hoping but
I was talking to virzi my gambling buddy
and he was putting money on the Patriots
and when he saw when Rex Ryan said you
know it's gonna be me verbally check he
texts me and was going dude it's over
it's over
why would he do that that's the dumbest
[ __ ] thing to say but bah bah bah bah
bah and I don't know you guys won't
believe me if I tell you the whole week
I was going look dude our defense shots
and I've been saying that all [ __ ]
year it's gone oh dude dude it's just
like the Giants when the Giants went on
their [ __ ] run no what is it it isn't
and then he said something else he goes
well don't worry I go do we let up like
24 to 26 points a [ __ ] game for
two-thirds of the season we're starting
four [ __ ] rookies and he goes yeah
but dude dude you score like 35 points a
game and that that's what my [ __ ] by
heart sank into my stomach and I was
like wow he just described
Dan Marino's career how are we gonna win
the Superbowl we don't have a defense I
don't worry we got Marino hey daddy why
don't you go out and score 40 today that
only works in the regular season so I
was like look all they got to do if they
establish the run we're [ __ ] because
they're gonna chew up the clock and then
Brady is not gonna be on the field he
can't hurt you if he's not in the field
so that's what I was worried about I was
hoping we were gonna rape the Jets but I
was worried that if they got their
running game going if LT started [ __ ]
running we were gonna be in trouble okay
because I didn't buy into the [ __ ]
hype where it's like wow this is what we
did the last time yeah but the time
before we lost all right exactly we lost
28 to 14 five [ __ ] years ago we lost
like four months ago so is what this is
honestly in my heart of hearts what I
think happened the Patriots came out and
they picked up right where they let off
and then Brady threw arguably the worst
pass of his career and I think the
Patriots just got spooked they got they
was stunned and then the Jets got run
the ball down right down to like what
like the 12 yard line and then they came
out like the [ __ ] Keystone Cops that
first series Sanchez goes to hand off
the ball and he trips his [ __ ]
running back then they ran a [ __ ] I
blocked so much of this game up because
of the pain of watching the Patriots
lose but some sort of sweep and whoever
was running it faked somebody out and
then bumped into his own lineman and
then they missed the field goal and I
was like all right the Jets are tight
the Jets are tight they're [ __ ]
nervous and then the Patriots came and I
really think though because Brady had
not [ __ ] up since October I think
because of the hype of the game they
were like oh [ __ ] not now not to this
team and for the rest of the game they
were pressing and they went right down
the [ __ ] field
he throws a touchdown pass and the guy
drops it they get a field goal and then
I just feel like the rest of the game
they play
in panic mode like they were up three to
nothing and they were playing well our
defense sucks that they just it sucks
but like the offense would come out and
the Jets went up seven to three and the
Patriots come out like they're down 28
to 3
I just felt they'd never gotten to the
rhythm a lot of it was because the Jets
had a monster [ __ ] pass rush but I
just it just was like you know they
[ __ ] call the fake punt you drop a
touchdown pass
you dropped the fake punt you throw a
first down to Deion Branch and he
[ __ ] drops it it was like they they
would just I just don't think they up
they needed to go down on that first
drive and score a touchdown and the last
thing they needed was Brady to throw a
pick and they just never got go we got
going for half a second when we scored
that touchdown and had the two-point
conversion and it was 14 to 11 and then
then we had the momentum we had great
and we [ __ ] nailed the guy on the
kickoff and I'm like okay our defense
has to pull one out of their ass here
and [ __ ] clamp them down and we have
to get the ball back and it was a moment
in the fun that was the moment in the
game and [ __ ] mark Trent Dilfer
Sanchez throws a [ __ ] 8 yard pass
that turns into a 70 yard [ __ ] game
and that would that for me that was
[ __ ] that was it that was it even
though we scored that touchdown in the
end it just it just wasn't our [ __ ]
day even we do onside kicks in the
[ __ ] ball seem to be laying there 4x
8 seconds and we were running around
where is it I don't see a jet with it I
can't find it anyways but
congratulations to the Jets man you know
you got to hand it to him do it they
talked [ __ ] and they came in and they
[ __ ] won but I got to be honest it
wasn't as amazing as everybody's making
it out to be the same way the Patriots
are not as amazing as they were made out
to be going into this [ __ ] game and
it's why I don't watch ESPN and I don't
I watched the gay I had the game on mute
because I knew the game was gonna take
seven years off my life unless it went
like that 45 to three game which to be
honest jet fans I was still nervous when
we were up like 28 to nothing that's how
bad our [ __ ] defense was on that game
but like I don't I don't know I guess
because they're trying to get ratings
but I don't get how you go one in one
during the regular season and then
whatever you did the last time you try
to act like that's who the [ __ ] you are
and that's who the other guy is or like
the Jets like there's nothing - I gotta
like emails from jet fans this one guy
goes the dynasty is over and it's like
dude we haven't won a Super Bowl since
2004 it's been over for seven [ __ ]
years the dynasty ended when Tedy
Bruschi had that that [ __ ] mild
stroke or seizure or whatever he had
that was the end of it and then we you
know we lost a few guys we were never
quite the same
but the thing is that's been the same
has been Belichick and Brady so people
are acting like they're beating this
Super Bowl team this is the team that
got raped by the Ravens last year first
round of the [ __ ] playoffs and you
know so I don't know
so whatever congratulations I still have
yet to be proven wrong about the Jets
though okay if you guys remember because
people forget what I said they said they
were going to win the [ __ ] Super Bowl
and they talked to all this [ __ ] [ __ ]
all they have achieved at this point is
getting back to the game that they lost
last year so but you know whatever my
team's out of it so I'm done being a
[ __ ] so whatever good luck jet fans you
got a 42-year monkey on your back I know
what that's like x 2plus [ __ ] four
years two years of whatever was 8686
[ __ ] years so good luck to you this
is the thing this let me give you the
backstory I was watching this game by
myself at the Borgata in in Atlantic
City by myself with the mute on on the
game because I can't when games are that
big I can handle any
sort of comment that I consider moronic
because at one point dianna branch
caught a ball and he was all amped up
and he was yelling over at the Jets
sidelines and I unn hit mute and I hear
Phil Simms going D on branch and he's
yelling at Rex Ryan I don't know why
he'd be doing that yeah why would he why
would he why would he yell at that guy
who's been talking [ __ ] saying that the
Brady that the Brady that the Patriots
aren't a good team and people on that
team are Colin Brady an [ __ ] yeah why
do you think there would be some sort of
chatter Phil Simms did you play your
entire career with the Bose headphones
on you [ __ ] uh drove me nuts oh I had
[ __ ] hit mute I had to hit mute and
uh it was [ __ ] brutal and I was and I
texted virzi at halftime
this was another turning point at a
half-time okay first of all what the
[ __ ] we gave the goddamn Jets the ball
on our own 48 or 30 yard line four
[ __ ] times in the first half the fact
that we weren't down like 28 to 3 at the
half was a minor miracle and the defense
actually was stepping up in that half
but you know I knew it was gonna come
down to the [ __ ] defense because I
know a lot of Patriot fans think it was
the [ __ ] offense but the offense is
entitled to have a bad day to struggle
every once in a [ __ ] blue moon okay
that's when the defense has to step it
up and we just did not have a defense
that could do that okay if the defense
could have stepped it up and got some
three and outs Brady in them they would
have got into a rhythm we just couldn't
get into a [ __ ] rhythm because our
defense has been like room-temperature
butter all [ __ ] year so anyways when
we got that personal foul call that
undisciplined play that like the San
Diego Chargers would do back in the day
I was just like I was I hate to say it I
was like this [ __ ] game is over you
know I still watched because I can't
bail on my [ __ ] team I still watch
but I was just like this [ __ ] game is
over like they have completely been
rattled by the Jets they're completely
out of their [ __ ] game plan
and they're playing like I'd like an
inexperienced [ __ ] team and I texted
Paul virzi and I wrote I [ __ ] and
then in capital letters told you we had
this big debate was working down the
Comedy Cellar Friday and I get ready for
my big shows with Dave Attell Jim Breuer
and Jim and Jim Norton down at the
Borgata so I didn't want to be the weak
link on that [ __ ] gigantic comedy
show so I was doing my [ __ ] around the
city and virzi gave me a ride home and
he was gone dude it's gonna be a
bloodbath I'm telling you it's gonna be
a [ __ ] bloodbath and I was going Paul
our defense sucks all they got to do is
run the ball but that bet you know
what's funny is that didn't even that
neither thing that we said happened I
thought the Jets were really gonna
establish the [ __ ] run and chew up
the clock that's what I thought was
gonna happen and no way shape or form
did I think Tom Brady was gonna have
that bad of a game I mean dude they were
[ __ ] off did you see that one play
where Gronkowski he's running a go
pattern and Brady throws an out it was
just like what what the [ __ ] is going
they were completely rattled and I don't
know if it I think it was the
interception slash all this [ __ ] talk
and the Jets were doing I think that
they wanted to beat him that [ __ ] bad
that when he [ __ ] up with that [ __ ]
Jesus Christ I mean that that thing was
like if rex grossman made us
instructional video on how to throw
whatever that pass was it wasn't a
[ __ ] screen pass I don't know what it
was it was just oh my god it was just
like I mean he picked it up and I was
like oh no oh no not now not this week
not to this [ __ ] team so I have to go
down this is the funny thing this is the
funniest thing about all of this I've
talked so much [ __ ] about the Jets this
year
last week the Jets lose to the [ __ ]
Colts yet win the [ __ ] game which is
why I think the
the Jets could win because when you win
a championship
not only are you good but you have that
stepped and [ __ ] luck the top rule what
the [ __ ] was that right all right [ __ ]
it give us the ball back yeah we win the
helmet catch you just and with the Jets
you have the Colts calling timeout with
29 seconds left you know just in case we
get the ball back with 5.5 seconds left
I think we'll call the timeout here and
have mediocre Mark Sanchez with the
[ __ ] deer-in-the-headlights give him
a nice minute to chill out gather his
thought give Rex an opportunity to give
them next three play so he can chill out
next play 18 yard completion game over
you got to have that stepped and [ __ ]
look and I just feel like I feel like
the Jets have that they have that oh my
god we're gonna lose this game and then
somebody hits somebody out of bounds for
no [ __ ] reason oh wait a minute we
just got a first down
so I don't know this should be a great
[ __ ] game this week alright and I
love being a jet hater I love that the
Jets beat Pittsburgh the last time and
that the game is in Pittsburgh and that
Polamalu is playing this week and and I
love that ESPN will probably hight the
[ __ ] out of the Jets that's what I'm
hoping that's what I'm hoping so anyway
so I'm sitting there let's get to the
misery now the misery of my [ __ ] life
that day so I'm sitting there okay on
one of the most unbelievable [ __ ]
weekend's I've ever done in comedy like
I got to work with Jim Norton Jim Breuer
and Dave Attell myself we were all on
the same show at the Borgata we played a
2100 seater or 20 whatever did the
[ __ ] big one and we sold it out three
[ __ ] times and I was just sitting
there thinking like how [ __ ] him it
first of all I had not seen Jim let's
let's go through the lineup here I had
not seen Jim Norton do stand-up a
headlining set since before the Opie and
Anthony virus tours that's how [ __ ]
long it's been because me and him came
up together so when I started headlining
he started headlining and he actually
blew up before most of us from our
graduating class he got on the Opie and
Anthony show pre that whole scandal in
the church he was already headlining so
I never got to really I never got to
work with him so he was he opened the
show so in I and I was going on next so
I got to stand there every [ __ ] night
watching him work watching him switch
some jokes around and absolutely killing
he was [ __ ] hilarious he's got this
bit on that new show quarters that [ __ ]
had killed me every night and it was it
was [ __ ] awesome because you know I do
the road I do it you know when I go out
I go with the roads I go with virzi but
I don't get to work with any of my peers
like the guys that I started out with
anymore and then on top of that then I
had Brewer in a tell and those were the
guys when I came down from Boston and I
was this [ __ ] nerd new comic and I'd
be in the back of the Boston comedy club
with like my backpack I swear to God I
had a backpack right because I would
walk around you know on the subway and I
had all my [ __ ] in there my comedy
notebook you know just in case comedy
inspiration at me I was a total [ __ ]
nerd and I used to sit at the back of
the Boston comedy club which they should
make a [ __ ] movie about that place
it was the rawest most intimidating
[ __ ] room I ever went into I mean in
a lot of ways it was worse I did the
Apollo one time it was worse than that
because the Apollo there's this odd sort
of no pressure because you're expecting
to get booed
still you don't want to get booed but if
you get booed I mean the amount of
people like Lauryn Hill like famous
Superstars have gotten booed so it's not
that bad but like the way the Boston
Comedy Club was run back in the day was
completely opposite to all the other
comedy clubs that I make at least in my
experience like this is how they would
do it they would you
if you came down and you were a new
comic and they were gonna put you on
they put you on early in the show and
they tried to you know assess where you
were as a comedian by sticking you
basically in the show where they figured
your talents we're at which is you know
if you're newer they put you earlier in
the show the boston comedy club if you
came down oh yeah your new comic you
want to go on all right they put you on
like three quarters through the show
after like [ __ ] louis c.k Jim Breuer
Jay Mohr had just leveled the [ __ ]
room and then you date the guy you want
to go on next right and you what
literally would feel like you know those
Spike Lee movies where the main
character that he'd be focusing on is
just standing there but the background
is like slowly pulling away that's
that's what I would feel like and I
would immediately go from you know
feeling like you know five foot ten to
feeling like I was like three foot ten
and I it was [ __ ] unbelievable I was
the worst and then all comics hung out
in the back and you were convinced that
they all thought you sucked and they
were all watching yeah it was it was
brutal so anyway so I got to work with
those guys this weekend and I'm sitting
there like a fan all weekend and the
crowds were amazing and but the whole
weekend this [ __ ] Jets Patriots game
is looming and I'm sitting there going
this [ __ ] game can go either goddamn
way they won once we won once I don't
know what the [ __ ] everybody's talking
about like this is gonna be a cakewalk
our defense sucks all right and I'm just
sitting there at one point it was
actually last week when the Jets beat
the Colts I'm sitting there going like
you gotta be [ __ ] kidding me
I'm literally talking to the comedy gods
going what are the [ __ ] odds that the
team I've been talking [ __ ] about for
the entire [ __ ] year he's not only
gonna make the playoffs back into the
[ __ ] playoffs
lose a playoff game but then [ __ ] win
the [ __ ] thing the
week they're gonna play my [ __ ] team
all right and I'm gonna be in New Jersey
the [ __ ] game is at 4 o'clock or 4:30
whatever the [ __ ] it is and I go onstage
at 8 in New Jersey in front of a bunch
of [ __ ] jet fans why does this keep
happening to me
it's unfuckin I can't I can't explain it
I go down to Philly all that [ __ ]
[ __ ] out I guess that had nothing to do
about sports sports pulled me out of the
mud down there another [ __ ] time I
have a random weekend booked at
Caroline's a random [ __ ] weekend they
booked it like 6 7 8 months out and lo
and behold the weekend I come in the
first night I come in the night I fly in
to do morning press I flew in on like a
[ __ ] Thursday at Wednesday I can't
remember what the [ __ ] Yankees win
the World Series and I'm staying in
Times Square I'm trying to sleep and I
can't because all I hear is out in the
[ __ ] outside my hotel window and I'm
sitting there with pillows on each side
[ __ ] head so now I'm sitting there
and I'm going this is classic my career
this is either gonna be [ __ ] amazing
or an absolute goddamn debacle and I was
sitting in my [ __ ] hotel room and
Brady threw that pic and I was like oh
my god oh my god please no please please
don't not this week for the love of
[ __ ] God could you not I'm trying to
go a hundred days without boozing can
you not do it this week I know we're not
good enough to win the Superbowl this
[ __ ] year I know we're gonna lose in
the playoffs but can we just not lose to
these [ __ ] shit-talking [ __ ] please
write and then they [ __ ] Keystone
copped it and missed a field goal and we
drove down them and I ended it just and
just it just [ __ ] unraveled and the
whole time I'm sitting there going what
is going to happen at my
stand up show what cuz I already have
been walking around the casino that day
and all I'm seeing is Jets jerseys I see
a couple of I'm in [ __ ] Atlantic City
New Jersey
alright the Eagles are not in the
playoff there's no playoffs there's no
Eagles fans there it's Jets fans and I
get this show to [ __ ] do and I
perform in an art where it's okay to
yell oh you [ __ ] suck you [ __ ]
it's okay to do that and I'm watching my
team unravel and I'm just sitting there
ironing my show shirt going I'm not only
do I got to do a podcast and eat [ __ ]
crow I now have to go down and dance
like a [ __ ] monkey for a bunch of
goddamn elated jet fans who are who are
probably gonna be yelling J ETS Jets
Jets Jets every time I'm trying to do a
punchline
why does this keep happening to me why
couldn't I bet in [ __ ] Ohio alright
so now it's 7:30 the game is basically
[ __ ] over and then there's a knock on
the door it's security to bring me
downstairs which is absolutely [ __ ]
hilarious like you know like I need that
but you know I'll feed my [ __ ] ego
and the door opens up and I was just
like I [ __ ] knew it I [ __ ] knew it
I [ __ ] called it that [ __ ] virzi
[ __ ] he's not answering his [ __ ]
phone I [ __ ] told him I [ __ ] told
him I knew this was gonna [ __ ] happen
right
and the guy takes me downstairs and I'm
thinking well you know what's great
about this [ __ ] is they're taking me the
Goodfellas way so I can go down in the
elevator I'm in the catacombs behind the
[ __ ] massive theater I'll just sit
there I'll watch the final [ __ ]
minutes of the game
you know cuz unlike those other [ __ ]
Fairweather [ __ ] fans who left Gillette
Stadium you know I'll get to that later
but there's a reason why they build
stadiums as big as they do it's for
all the Fairweather [ __ ] fans alright
and it's also why you should never be
upset if somebody you love doesn't
return a [ __ ] fan letter because
that's what fans are that's what they
are
you know entertain me I love you as long
as you do what I want and then you don't
when you're down I'm gonna walk out on
you and I'm guilty of it too I've had
plenty of [ __ ] people that I've been
fans of that went broke I never sent him
any goddamn money I just I just talked
to my friend - what the [ __ ] happened
what happened to leif Garrett leif
Garrett so anyway so I'm going down into
the end then I'm thinking well whatever
you know what what the [ __ ] there's no
way it's gonna be worse than Philly I
just got to address it the second I go
out there right so um but at least I can
just have this moment of peace and
[ __ ] deal with the fact that what I
kind of knew was gonna happen was gonna
happen I just didn't want it to happen
to the Jets so I'm [ __ ] decompressing
from that loss I gotta set it aside
because now I have to go [ __ ] out
there and be dance like a goddamn clown
so as I'm sitting there watching the
final [ __ ] seconds of it all of a
sudden I hear Jim Breuer coming down the
[ __ ] Corte go and you [ __ ] believe
this [ __ ] you [ __ ] it just keeps
getting louder I'm like police don't
walk into my dressing room and he just
comes walking in he's like the [ __ ]
Patriot did he starts miming jerking off
in my face and he goes like he just blew
a load in my face right he goes [ __ ] you
[ __ ] like I had been talking
[ __ ] all weekend it proceeds to start
trashing me in the Patriots and it was
actually [ __ ] hilarious because I saw
in him I saw me last year screaming
about Peyton Manning because you only
hear [ __ ] about your team you know you
never hear anything fair and balanced
and he's sitting there cuz that's going
oh Tom Brady he's so great his [ __ ]
quarterback ever
it was literally my rent from last year
about Peyton Manning so ah was I getting
my Just Desserts and I he just kept
trashing me and then I said I'll [ __ ]
you you still haven't won one since 1969
he goes [ __ ] you you sound like a Yankee
fan [ __ ] and he's like I took a
pounding from him um classic jet fan
though didn't say [ __ ] before the game
was all [ __ ] nervous just like every
was everybody was admit it I didn't get
any emails from jet fans and afterwards
you know it only got a few and it was
from the usual kunti ones that uh you
know
really need to go hug their dad or
whatever so then I'm sitting there going
oh my god and Norton came in and he was
kind of [ __ ] laughs and he goes you
bummed out I go yeah I got I know I'm
past into it I got to do this and I go
my guys gonna be a lot of jet fans out
tonight isn't there why why comedy gods
why did I have to be in Atlantic City
why did I have to be working with Jim
Breuer as much as I [ __ ] loved the guy
why did I have to work be working with
the jet fan you know why because I
deserved it cuz I've been talking [ __ ]
all [ __ ] year I actually became what I
didn't want to be when I was thrashing
Rex Ryan for so anyway so now I'm
standing out in the way 20 [ __ ] 100
people so I'm peeking through the
curtain right like some [ __ ] open mic
ER who's never been on stage before I
look in the front row and what do I see
I see like five jet jerseys some fat
[ __ ] with the Jets hat unless gone uh
god oh god here we go here we go god
damn it if I if I could clone myself
right now and put a [ __ ] goddamn I'm
doing stand-up sport coat on this person
I would so Jimmy goes out there in all
week he just kept he just kept getting
funnier it was it was really [ __ ]
awesome watching him and he actually
took one joke that was killing in the
the end of a set he put at the beginning
and it [ __ ] just destroys and then
he's just murder him think he murdered
him twice Saturday night but his clearly
just [ __ ] taking it to another level
and I'm just laughing going and
Jimmy's gonna have a set where I can't
even follow him really comedy gods this
is really gonna [ __ ] happen and I'm
sitting there and then this is okay for
all you comedians out there I was like
all right what do I got to do well how
am I gonna get out of this what is what
is the I can't just go out there and
start doing my [ __ ] act and act like
nothing's happening I was thinking of
going out there in the second they
started yelling about the jet so it's
gonna be like no no no no I'm taping the
game don't tell me what happens don't
tell me what happened but that would be
funny for like three [ __ ] seconds so
I finally it's just going like what I
always do whenever I before I'm going
out on stage and I just don't feel like
I'm gonna have a good set and I don't
feel like I'm funny I just said what am
I feeling what am I thinking I am
thinking [ __ ] I can't believe the
Patriots lost and of all [ __ ] states
that I have to be and to watch them lose
to the team that I hate the most right
now why did I have to be in New Jersey
and I was literally like that there's
your opener that is your opener and
that's what I went out to and all the
Jets fans would die in [ __ ] laughing
and then they left me alone they didn't
give a [ __ ] they were [ __ ] elated and
although I couldn't I couldn't slow down
at any point during my set like the
crowds were so great all weekend usually
when you have a crowd that big you can't
really bring them down to try to build
it back up again you have to kind of
just kill the whole time I noticed you
could bring them down which was so great
the whole weekend but but during that
set every time I would bring it down
there would always be one guy [ __ ]
chance
[Laughter]
so so I took my pounding so there you go
congratulations seriously and I got it I
have to I have to admit sup the two I
walk by like you know when your team
[ __ ] loses a game like this will you
give a [ __ ] like this you cannot watch
ESPN for a good three days and I haven't
been able to do that a lot this year I
couldn't do it when the Ravens raped us
I guess was a year ago when the Ravens
raped us last year in the playoffs
playoffs I didn't watch it for like
three [ __ ] days
when the Lakers beat us in Game seven
you know when they were their 12th man
came off the bench with those striped
shirts and just started [ __ ] calling
fouls and technical fouls and all that
[ __ ] I'll never get over that by the way
I didn't watch it for like [ __ ] I
couldn't I couldn't even watch TV cuz I
live in Los Angeles I had to close the
windows
Lakers [ __ ] I had to deal with that
and then this one I've had three bad
things come in threes right people I
don't believe in that either you just
you just start recounting after three
and this is one of them I just turned
but I just could not watched I still
have not watched one second of ESPN I
flip by real quick with with the with
the mute button on and if there's a game
on I watch the game but I walked by a TV
and I saw Rex Ryan doing a press
conference I only heard a couple things
he had but he had a genuine look of joy
in his face and for half a second I was
actually somewhere in my jet hatin mind
happy for the guy like a damn
[ __ ] he did it and he [ __ ]
did it that son of a [ __ ] you know
whatever I might be a [ __ ] foot I can't
take it to the level of truly wishing
that level of misery
you know they haven't won it since 1969
but be honest with yourself this is I
think when you you realize if you're a
problem fan where you're taking it to
the point where you're really just it
like the point that I've taken it where
it's just no fun to be a sports fan when
you literally take it to the point where
you don't want like I remember like the
I probably aged like 11 years after the
Red Sox won in 2004 every year praying
for the Yankees to never win another
[ __ ] World Series like that wasn't
gonna happen you know 200 million
dollars every [ __ ] here on the table
you know plus a [ __ ] great
organization to happen it's just
too much [ __ ] energy so my team is
out of it I am done [ __ ] talking and
even if the Jets [ __ ] lose out I'm
not gonna do that to you because you
beat my team and that and that's you
know that's a [ __ ] [ __ ] move I'm not
gonna do it so seriously from the bottom
of my jet hating heart congratulations
to all you guys you deserve it enjoy
your [ __ ] week and know this that's
you guys next week now carry the
pressure of being the only thing that
stands in the way of a date rapist
possibly going on to win his third Super
Bowl championship
[Music]
dude Ben Roethlisberger quietly very
quietly I mean date rape charges really
drown out a lot of on the field success
let's be fair very quietly could join
the ranks of as far as I know if he wins
his third one he's on the only he's with
Tom Brady and Troy Aikman they're the
only other guys who have won three right
and then there's only two guys have won
four is Montana and Bradshaw
am I correct am I missing somebody I
thought Jim Plunkett for half a second
but that was Kenny Stabler in 77 so oh
oh let me tell judge fans I gotta get
yeah I got a oh this - you guys I got to
let you know all my misery so at the end
of the show the show [ __ ] ends and
it's the end of the week and I took a
bunch of pictures with [ __ ] jet fans
wearing jerseys and it was actually we
it was actually ended up being a good
time but the the best thing was
afterwards you know Norton in Natal left
cuz you know they live in New York they
took off Brewer was handed with hangin
with some friends so I go back to my
[ __ ] room by myself no security no
nothing but not like I needed it but I
walked back through the catacombs the
[ __ ] Goodfellas way by myself just
thinking about the loss all I hear is
the sound of my shoes hitting the tile
floor
walking to that service elevator that
looks like [ __ ] because they you know
they move furniture in it went up to my
floor went into this amazing suite that
they had given me by myself i sat there
I ordered room service and by myself
with the TV off and only one light on in
silence I ate a cheeseburger some french
fries and I got some cheesecake for
dessert and I just sat there I couldn't
put the TV on and I just sat there and
silence and then it hit me and I was
like oh my god I have to do the podcast
and relive this so there you go I hope
you jet fans deserved not deserve I'll
be jet fans enjoyed that and I I
apologize that I when I got off the
plane that I didn't come home I didn't
come right home into a podcast I could
have but I really wanted to make sure
that I did it justice that I got a good
night's sleep god I didn't want to do a
lame podcast that podcast last week
sucked I was getting ready to leave
that's the worst podcast I think I've
ever done and I wanted to make sure that
I you know I tried to remember all of my
misery because I really felt you know
that's one of the joys of winning is
when a loudmouth [ __ ] from the other
team you know they're miserable so I
hope I didn't leave any details out I
got a couple of emails I don't know but
here's one that somebody said there was
a couple of things I thought was funny
some guy a Jets fan who went up to
Foxborough oh you know what I I have a I
have a feeling I'm just worried I'm not
gonna end up talking about the amazing
look can I just talk about how great
Atlantic City was and why you guys have
to see this show because I think we're
gonna take it to Connecticut at one of
the casinos up there and even if we
don't if things don't work out which I
know they're going to because it was a
[ __ ] I want to thank everybody who
came out
the show's it was really a [ __ ] event
and I don't overhype shows that I'm on
but it was arguably one of the the best
comedy show easily that I've been on in
the last [ __ ] 10 years and it's the
strongest tour I bet I I think I've ever
been on I mean those Opie and Anthony
ones were [ __ ] amazing those were
amazing though especially that night in
Philly that's what's so funny about
those [ __ ] idiot Philly fans if you
saw the Latino the lineup that night was
Patrice O'Neal Robert Kelly Tracy Morgan
Ralphie May Jim Norton me who else was
out there I'm gonna forget Bob say it
was [ __ ] insane it was like one of
the N of those Rock and Roll Hall of
Fame shows where they bring out like
[ __ ] all these musicians and stick
them on the stage and then somehow it
always sucks is it ever good when you
have 58 guitarists and 19 drummers that
never it never sounds good and then they
always play like mama kin or some [ __ ]
standard hail hail rock and roll or some
stupid [ __ ] that they this is what is
the first job we played we was 16 except
it was actually a great show but this is
so this would be the strongest one that
I've been on since the ona virus tour
and Opie and Anthony came down to and
was [ __ ] great I was hanging out with
both of them Anthony is absolutely
[ __ ] hilarious and there needs to be a
documentary made about people who play
blackjack he came he came in from
playing blackjack and he had sweat under
his armpits like he had been playing
full court basketball in a turtleneck
sweater it was awesome and I went on
what I watched him gamble and he was
hilarious he was cursing out this
[ __ ] [ __ ] who did not him didn't
know how to gamble he [ __ ] hit on 17
went over and then the dealer got 21 and
I swear to God if Anthony killed him
right then and there I I would have I
would have become an accessory to murder
not in that I would have helped him kill
him but I definitely would have helped
to hide Anthony from the authorities do
you mind if we come in mr. Berg do you
ever wore it
yes we do yeah just just stay out of the
bedroom it's not really cleaned up
anyways it was an unbelievable night and
I don't know when we're gonna do the
show again but I have to tell you if you
get a chance to see any of those three
[ __ ] guys like Jim Norton's that is
the funniest I've ever [ __ ] seen him
Dave Attell is a [ __ ] beast and Jim
Breuer
I'm telling you has one of the top 10
funniest [ __ ] bits I've ever seen
yeah obviously I'm not gonna you know
ruin what the [ __ ] it is but it starts
off I was standing up watching him and
by the time he was done I was slumped
down I mean it's a [ __ ] dirty casino
rug if I could have [ __ ] been laying
on the ground laughing I would have but
I was actually you know I was crouching
down you ever see like when they gamble
in China you know how they crouch down I
was sort of sitting like that but I was
[ __ ] dying laughing like lean
sideways into the wall this is how funny
the joke was I actually was downstairs
in the greenroom at one point and called
Nia while Jim was on stage and he could
hear the show and I put the phone up to
the bit and she was dying laughing so if
you guys get a chance to see any of them
go on their web sites go see them
because it was just a [ __ ]
unbelievable weekend and I really really
hope that we get to do it again and and
I want to thank Jim Norton for putting
the whole thing together it's just a
great idea and the fans were [ __ ]
amazing they were quiet they would laugh
and then they then they would be quiet
and let you set it up I felt like I was
working at the cellar you know where you
are just a great comedy room but it was
this [ __ ] 2,200 seater conference
room so I hope you guys all had a great
time I got ridiculous emails about
people telling me how funny the show was
and I got like three emails from people
telling me that was the first comedy
show they ever went to well all I can
say is you picked the [ __ ] right one
so that's it so I'll let you guys know
when we're gonna be doing more all right
so here's here's an email I got from a
jet
fan who went up to Gillette Stadium all
right Pat fans are all scumbags who shop
at LL Bean be honest Patriot fans if you
really remove yourself from the
situation and you go buy a Patriots
tailgate you know you know those [ __ ]
boots that are like they're like leather
on top but they're made out of rubber on
the bottom they'll shoot those boots are
actually the [ __ ] yeah we are a bunch of
rubes the same way if you go down to
Giants Stadium it's like the [ __ ]
Jersey Shore meets you know those Artie
Lange looking guys you know and I'm not
trashing Artie Lange because look at me
I am a pasty-faced Mick from Boston that
was you know we really are the faces of
our state when I think of New Jersey I
definitely think of an RD Laing type of
a guy and though when you think of
Massachusetts don't you think about a
book some Conan O'Brien bill burr
looking [ __ ] high a thi thi thi to so
I'm not gonna lie with you and I'm not
gonna say that we aren't scumbags up
there we are dude I got a system just
got in from Foxborough the experience
was a good time expected some heckling
going and made it out without getting
hassled too hard overall was an awesome
experience watching all Pat fans empty
the stadium before the game was over my
section was packed with Jets fans felt
bad for the guy and his daughter who was
surrounded on every side I guess by jet
fans I'm not sure if it's Foxborough or
NFL fans in general that are just
degenerate scumbag since I've only been
to the Meadowlands prior to this for NFL
games but here's a small list of [ __ ] I
saw throughout the day I saw a guy and
his girlfriend get real racist with one
Jets fan sitting in front of them yeah
that's that's Boston until he spit beer
on the wrong group of people and it
turned into a Pats fan versus Pats fan
fight you know funny that is because
I've always resented Gillette Stadium
and the lighthouse and the way they pave
over the the scumbag experience that
going to a Patriots game used to be over
in Foxboro Stadium I hated how when we
became a championship team all those
corporate seats and all those [ __ ]
white collared douchebags who started
showing up it was a [ __ ] keg party
from nineteen [ __ ] seventy right
through most of Bill Parcells time not
until we started winning championships
and the [ __ ] started turning around that
all of a sudden there was this expecting
to win vibe and everybody started acting
classy the bottom line is no fans no
fans are classy
unless you're winning then when you're
winning it's easy to be like you know
they're just bunch of classes people you
know what kind of behavior is that it's
like dude why don't you look into your
[ __ ] closet and remember how you
acted it's like Yankee fans remember
that [ __ ] it was always Reds fan Red Sox
fans are scumbags we have no class in
blah blah blah blah and this is all why
the Yankees were winning and then I
remember when a rod slapped the ball out
of was it Bronson Arroyo glove and the
call went against him for the first time
in history the Yankees got caught
cheating you know after all the years of
pulling homeruns into the [ __ ] stands
and leaning into balls during a when you
picked off they've call finally went
against him and the fee Anki fans these
classy [ __ ] metropolitan we live in
the Paris of United States littered the
[ __ ] filled with [ __ ] trash
alright so there you go sir so yes let
me just finish he says uh but Papa I saw
a dude cut off an entire line of track
it and throw beers at someone's car this
is obviously after the game well maybe
it was before the game who knows and
when confronted threatened the dude and
said he was going to get his gat and I
also saw a bunch of douche bags on the
way on the way out on that shitty
two-lane highway guilty as charged
route 1 baby spiking beers at people's
cars and dead stop traffic
looking to the Ford looking forward to
the podcast and gloating all week yeah
yeah definitely um ya know if you go if
you go around the league if you go
around the league yeah sports fans are
if they're losing their yet they are
scumbags no but nobody's a good loser
you know but there are definitely worse
ones and someone actually asked me
because it was one Patriots fan I like
this guy he was pissed at all the Pats
fans that left and I know a lot of Jets
fans are going yeah the [ __ ] lame as
[ __ ] fans it's oh [ __ ] you you green
[ __ ] you do it too everybody does it
everybody does it and the only those
people who stay those are diehard fans
and if you notice it's like 26 [ __ ]
people
okay you know those years when your team
is like 1 in 15 and 2 and 14 and there's
26 people at the game and you know when
your team is supposed to win some big
playoff game and then they they [ __ ]
lose and you're so embarrassed and but
there's and it's just that same 26
people that's the die-hard family and
the only reason why they make the
stadium's that [ __ ] big is for the
good times when all the fair weather
[ __ ] show up that's why that's why and
you saw how many die-hard [ __ ]
Patriots fans they are there's the same
level of die-hard jet fans I'm telling
you with that little firemen walk out he
wouldn't would most jet fans walk out
then that 45 be honest you green [ __ ]
45 to 3 drubbing if that took place down
in the Meadowlands huh
I know I do I would've stayed oh I would
have been there with the hero going
don't worry I'm still here for you
you're full of [ __ ] you're full of [ __ ]
you would have been out there on the
[ __ ] awful Jersey Turnpike y'all
would have left I got so many emails of
people telling me they shut off the game
and discussed all that type of [ __ ]
alright so shut the [ __ ] up most people
are Fairweather [ __ ] fans so you know
fans don't suck Pat fans are just a
they're an example of what most fans are
so I don't think you have any right
getting mad at an athlete if he doesn't
sign your autograph and sign you a
[ __ ] autograph
you know because most of you if they're
down forty five to three or twenty eight
[ __ ] twenty one down by seven onside
kick where the [ __ ] were you you're
already on route 1 so you have no right
getting mad at him but that's what
sports fans do they all suck look at all
those giant fans getting mad they had
the nerve to get mad at Tom Coughlin and
that and ask if he should be removed the
guy's like two and a half years removed
three years removed from beating and
undefeated 17 point favorite in the
Superbowl and now everybody's acting
like the game passed them by
I don't know so I know this has been
pretty much all sports this week it had
to be it had to be but Patriot fans okay
a lot of you are zoned out from watching
ESPN and all the hype about this
Patriots team you got understand what
Belichick did this year is he's
rebuilding a [ __ ] monster and the
fact that we were able to get as far as
we did with the team that we had that
awful [ __ ] defense to somehow go 14
and [ __ ] - when you let up 24 [ __ ]
points I can't wait to run into this
[ __ ] [ __ ] down at the Comedy
Store
another Patriots fan who was you know
what I hate wins when you have a sports
debate and somebody has a point okay and
not only do they not wait for you to
finish
they say that point and then then just
keep repeating it he goes Patriots are
gonna win it man they're gonna win the
[ __ ] Super Bowl Bill Belichick has
got these guys I go wait a minute do it
wait a minute they're letting up like
the defense is like last and everything
in the league three-quarters of season
he go stats told me nothing staff told
me nothing and I'm like dude they're
letting up 24 to 26 Jack don't mean
nothing
stats don't mean nothing now dude stats
don't mean everything I love Peyton
Manning they don't mean everything but
you know you can't ignore that
I can't wait to [ __ ] run into that
guy I'm just gonna walk up to him be
mean anything guys don't mean anything
and of course he won't remember and then
I'll just look like a psycho is he
drinking again
speaking of which people I am ninety
three [ __ ] days ninety three [ __ ]
days into into this hundred day John I
got seven I'm actually I'm sorry I'm
ninety four days to go so next week the
monday morning podcast I will be a
hundred days in and I'm actually going
to the Bruins LA Kings so just in case
you think I'm gonna retire as a sports
fan I'm not I have an odd sense of
[ __ ] relief I don't know maybe this
podcast was like cathartic I don't have
no idea what and I don't know I don't
know am I gonna be able to watch it next
week
I think jet I think Rex Ryan might be
that good you know when they say I tell
you you hate him but if he played for
you you'd pluck them love them you know
when they say about Ulf Samuelsson and I
say no no I wouldn't
there's something about Rex he reminds
me of all the meathead friends I had
when we used to go out drinking when I
was younger you know but he's very hard
to like he's very [ __ ] hard to like
you know he's fat and I was really you
know what it was about that guy did you
guys I don't know it was me did you guys
notice that he was losing weight rapidly
the entire year because of that lap-band
surgery and then right after that
Patriots lost he kind of leveled off for
half a second and maybe put on a few
pounds did you notice that you realized
like the level of M&Ms that guy was
eating you know after his I don't know
if I'll play him again like that for
days he was trying to [ __ ] calm down
his mind that was one thing I was
looking at I was like I hope this guy is
losing his [ __ ] mind and I just
really don't want to lose to these guys
and we did and oh it [ __ ] hurt it was
like the end of Braveheart except I did
cry out
and I didn't yell freedom but it
definitely began with an F word all
right there we go that's the end of that
[ __ ] so let's get on with the other
rest of the podcast people I am going to
be in Arlington Texas oh how funny is
this I actually have an opportunity to
go to the Super Bowl this year which
just train changed drastically because
this is Jets one not that I don't have a
ticket but there's no [ __ ] way I'm
gonna go there if the Jets are in it I'm
actually I might go cuz I think I'm
gradually getting past this [ __ ] you
know come on Super Bowl and [ __ ]
Dallas that would be awesome
and that's also you know if I'm back on
the sauce that could be a really good
[ __ ] time you know by the way is that
jet fan who's a fireman is he actually a
fireman and if he is what exactly does
he fight fires because he's on all the
home and away games how much money is he
making as a firefighter that he can
afford to do that is it one of those gay
things where he's the way that the the
[ __ ] team the ownership he's one of
our superfans and then he gets like free
season tickets is he part of the 9/11
clause is that what it is because he has
a fireman hat on that you know they're
like okay well we can't make this guy
buy tickets he's a firefighter we all
feel [ __ ] horrific after 9/11 let's
[ __ ] hook this guy up that guy's like
one of the luckiest sports fans ever
although I do notice they always stick
them down in the corner of the endzone
they don't quite hook him up on the
50-yard line
do they is he a fireman I have no idea
been making fun of that guy all weekend
I do know that he's very close with his
boyfriend who puts him on his shoulders
I still maintain that jet fans I will
not back down on that if that was my
[ __ ] son don't you ever put another
man on your [ __ ] shoulders with a
fireman's hat you understand me
if you had a [ __ ] mustache I would
never talk to you again do you
understand me huh hey [ __ ] talking to
you as long as you carry my [ __ ] last
name alright let go to your room and
think about it
alright let's try to get something out
of here let's try to get something
[ __ ] going on about this
right where are we where are we oh
here's a revenge story this one's
disgusting all right if there's any
women actually still listening to this
podcast after I did [ __ ] an hour
about a goddamn football game
all right revenge story and I wrote
gross in parentheses okay I don't know
if you still do those revenge stories
anymore but I thought I'd pass mine
along anyway all right I had this
roommate in college who would chew
loudly off that's what that was one of
my big pet peeves in life if you're a
[ __ ] adult and you eat with your
mouth open
I really think I should be able to leave
legally [ __ ] stab you in the jugular
with the utensil you're eating with
being a chopstick a fork a [ __ ] spoon
I got a [ __ ] spoon in there I will
butter knife slowly [ __ ] saw my way
into that he would chew too loudly
scream into the phone when I was trying
to watch TV
leave the toilet seat up when there were
ladies over and generally gross out my
girlfriend with his caveman-like habits
between that and his constant messes I
was having to clean up I got fed up
after a while I'm talking to nothing so
I had to get creative since we shared a
bathroom we also shared the toilet paper
all right people
I'm giving you an opportunity to hit
stop right now all right you can hit
stop you can hit pause you can
fast-forward it's probably gonna take me
another minute okay have you done it
because I'm gonna start reading in 3 2 I
took the role into my room unraveled it
and with my girlfriend's assistant drip
some leftover jizz on it let me read
that sentence again I took a roll into
my room unraveled it and with my
girlfriend's assistant assistants
dripped some leftover jizz on it I made
sure to space it out every few sheets so
that it was throughout the roll and in a
small enough quantity that wasn't
obvious just exactly how did you do that
will you
[ __ ] Chokin your [ __ ] on choking
choking on chunky joking is that what
you were doing did you have a [ __ ]
turkey baster this is disgusting
this is [ __ ] disgusting so he left a
small enough quantity so it wasn't
obvious the satisfaction of knowing that
when he wiped he would be rubbing my
semen into his ass made the annoying
habits far less annoying after after
that whenever he would chew loudly or be
annoying my girl and I would think of
what we we'd done and just start
laughing know that knowing that I had
planted my seed inside of him so to
speak highly recommended this too I
highly recommend this to anyone who has
an annoying roommate and has never been
tested and has tested negative for HIV
dude that is [ __ ] disgusting first of
all how do you know when he went in
there and wiped his ass why are you
thinking he's sticking his finger up his
ass and what did you do when you went in
and had to take a dump
you obviously brought in some different
toilet paper did you have like your ear
up to a glass waiting to hear the sound
of [ __ ] [ __ ] hitting the toilet water
and how did your girlfriend bring you to
climax with that toilet paper right
there she just rub you out like it was a
job and that's just [ __ ] disgusting
man that's really one of the creepier
ones I've ever gotten YouTube videos
this week I only have one of them
because I seriously like I said I was
flying back from Atlantic City and I I
didn't have time to go through all the
YouTube so I apologize I only have one
the left writes I'm on crack it's
actually a really cool music video
silly song maybe you can attach this
sort of what a happy one let me let me
do the I got a couple of advice and then
I'm gonna tap out here all right advice
I know this girl I've known her for a
bit we're friends we've been for a while
okay now this one you know everybody
always trashes me for the way I [ __ ]
read I know I suck at reading
but I have to let you know this is all
in lowercase and there's absolutely no
punctuation whatsoever I don't know if
this guy text message this or what but
this is not my [ __ ] fault let me try
my best to read this all right bill I
know this girl I've known her for a bit
and we're friends no period we've been
for a while comma anyway about a month
ago I asked her out on a date and she
said yes comma continuing this sentence
he doesn't have periods he just has
commas lowercase I took her out and we
had fun no period we talked [ __ ] was
hunky-dory no comma we kissed it no
period it was awesome first date it was
an awesome first date hey there's a
period no capital letter then I barely
[ __ ] heard from her no period I was
running around like a [ __ ] jackass no
period just trying to talk to her and
I'm sorry I guess it keeps going just
trying to talk to her and when we would
talk it was fine now there's a period I
was beating myself up going crazy no
period I was some piece of [ __ ] anyway I
pulled myself together and I asked her
out again she once again said yes
awesome right well not you [ __ ] lack
of punctuation that's not awesome so we
go out again went cool again I didn't
kiss her this time I don't know it was
just off
but anyway comma that was no punctuation
in all of that you [ __ ] dick once
again I was [ __ ] once again I [ __ ]
didn't hear a thing so I said [ __ ] it I
don't need this right now when we just
went back to being friends never talked
about it just let it lay [ __ ] seeing
double at this point anyway lately I've
been talking to her a lot like I said
like I said we're friends but she's very
clearly been flirting with me and I
honestly have been flirting back I still
like the girl no period no nothing but I
just don't know if it's worth it you
know period no question mark
she's got a lot of drama she's one of
these girls that gets drunk at a party
and cries then ask people if she's
pretty which she really [ __ ] is like
really hot dot dot dot dot dot uh but I
do like her I just don't know if I
should put myself through this [ __ ]
again what do you think bill I
legitimate legitimately would like your
advice slash opinion okay the first
thing I would do I get some sort of
spell check I would get some sort of
phonics or some sort of [ __ ] to teach
you how to write all right people I know
I suck at reading out loud but can can
you do me a [ __ ] solid I'm not
reading any more [ __ ] emails that
better like this alright because this is
literally I'm starting to lose my
[ __ ] eyesight um so what do I think
yeah okay this is what I think I think
you should definitely not get into a
relationship with this girl this girl
this girl is a [ __ ] nightmare alright
there's all kinds of red flags I don't
know what happened to her and I can tell
you right now you don't want to find out
what's happening to her what happened to
her you don't want to find out in that
you don't want to have feelings for this
girl alright and when the other [ __ ]
bag of [ __ ] hits the floor and your
heart is underneath it you don't you
don't you don't let a girl like this
break your heart all right you can see
it from a mile away she is a [ __ ]
mess alright there's plenty of great
girls out there you're a young guy go
find one alright find a girl you know
make a list of [ __ ] alright one of the
big things if you want to find a really
good girl is find one who has a great
relationship with her parents hopefully
they're still together
alright that's another good thing start
with that but if they sit there you go
friend they got low self-esteem issues
you're gonna kill a decade are you
[ __ ] life trying to build them up and
you know what it's gonna be it's gonna
be [ __ ] exhausting alright and then
because she doesn't think she's pretty
she might act out sexually for some sort
of you know I don't know like jeez I
just really have an hour and six minutes
in here just you know some sort of
affirmation that she
is pretty okay so what do I think you
should do all right well if you're a
well-adjusted guy you'll just walk away
from the situation and say that I'm not
gonna just bang her and use that as a
[ __ ] notch on my bedpost to make my
ego feel good and I'm not gonna hurt
this person but if you're how most
people are your age I would just say
bang her and then I don't know it's
gonna be ugly if you want to bang this
girl I gotta tell you don't let your
heart get involved and I don't know not
not having seen her not seeing how hot
she is
and being older and more mature I would
say just walk away and go find some
well-adjusted hottie that's unless you
just want to bang somebody but then you
can do that you know what is about this
thing you know I don't like there's too
much [ __ ] history you got to be able
to leave you got to be able to [ __ ] go
out the side door if you're just gonna
bang somebody you can't have this well
we were friends at first and then it
became romantic then we went back to
being friends and then we [ __ ] it's
just a [ __ ] nightmare yeah I'd find
someone else to [ __ ] but if you don't
give a [ __ ]
yeah I'd bang her but by no means don't
develop any sort of feelings for her all
right
there you go there's my advice I'm gonna
do one more and then that's it all right
this one has punctuation so if I [ __ ] up
this one is on me hey Bill first of all
I want to thank you for your breakup
advice I listened I think this is just a
thank you here I listened to the podcast
a few weeks ago and heard this guy's
story about getting dumped on Christmas
Eve oddly enough I was also at the end
of a relationship with a girl who had
had a kid she waited until a week after
New Year's when I was out of town sent
her flowers because I could tell
something was off something was up I
mean and I had been gone a lot recently
she called when I got off work and
confirmed my suspicions I don't need to
get into all that [ __ ] it happened and
the point is I just listened to your
podcast after it all happened and
decided that's how it had to be no point
and screwing anything else up in my life
no no point in worrying about anything
get back to the gym and focus on
finishing school in my career that's
right they
go there you go that's a great [ __ ]
move that's a self-esteem move right
there you're gonna find somebody else
you're gonna get somebody better go get
in great shape and get your career going
phenomenal [ __ ] move thanks for the
words of encouragement I think they did
some good big fan man I bought you a DVD
and I'll continue support of the podcast
well thank you very much I appreciate
that and thank you to everyone who's
been listening to my podcasts and once
again congratulations to the Jets their
organization and the fans you deserved
it you went into our stadium you kicked
our ass to the point that all you saw
how many true Patriots fans there
[ __ ] are but there are just as many
true jet fans be honest with yourselves
be honest with yourselves when they suck
do you watch them do you think I watched
a Celtic game from like 2002 to 2006
I didn't alright I jump right back on
that bandwagon I am a die-hard Bruin fan
diehard patriot fan I was a die-hard Red
Sox fan but you know what happened was
they won the World Series and I felt
like a degenerate gambler who finally
made a big score and I just walked away
from the table I was like that's it I'm
up I'm buying my little [ __ ]
houseboat I'm gonna throw down the
anchor and drink pina coladas the rest
of my life see you later thanks for the
memories and I haven't been able to get
back into him
since I got to be honest with you and
who else has left and the Celtics the
Celtics I got back into the Celtics you
know I'm not a big basketball fan I'm
not a big professional basketball fan
for the simple fact that the final three
minutes takes two hours and 17 minutes I
don't like how they travel and that's
all I'll all the time all the [ __ ]
time when I want you an NBA game that's
all I do is I just sit there watching
both teams even my team and I just go
[ __ ] the guy [ __ ] that was three and
a half steps travel
that that's you know I'm just not into
it but I do like it when the Celtics and
the Lakers are good that's when it's
great that's the rivalry I like [ __ ]
watching the same way it sucks
if the Canadiens are awesome and the
Bruins are bad or the other way around I
don't want the Canadiens to suck I want
it to be awesome
the Bruins to be awesome I like the
[ __ ] colliding and and that's it and
Patriots fans keeping [ __ ] heads up
especially the 26 a year who actually
stuck around to the end of the [ __ ]
game all right keep your heads up Bill
Belichick is [ __ ] the best goddamn
coach and you know what he did starting
for rookies on defense what he did this
year was [ __ ] phenomenal we laid an
egg in the worst possible time but uh
you know don't be a douche and put your
Pat's gear away for the [ __ ] year all
right don't be like that
don't be like or be like that who gives
a [ __ ] you think these athletes give a
[ __ ] about you you know you think
they're not gonna walk by in a [ __ ]
airport with their [ __ ] ten thousand
dollar headphones on actually they're
not even gonna walk by you on a head pin
at the [ __ ] Airport cuz they got
their own goddamn plane Wow Jesus you
know this podcast could really be
endless because I never run out of [ __ ]
to bet your bum that's the podcast for
this week that's it I will talk to you
next week god bless awliyas even the jet
fans you [ __ ] green [ __ ] and
everybody go [ __ ] yourselves
I'll see you
[Music]
[Applause]
you